on sait la fête depuis quelques minutes
et pour dix jours à cannes cannes rendez
vous international de la pellicule de la
pellicule par l'anc pour la 32e fois la
cuvée 79 promet d'être une année
particulièrement brillante envoyé
spécial d'antenne 2 sur la côte d'azur
france roche que nous devrions rejoindre
lauren bacall et karen black sont venus
d'amérique monica vitti d'italie yves
montand et jean claude brialy de paris
pour inaugurer ce dernier festival qui
est un festival de champion en effet on
n'a jamais vu autant de grands noms en
même temps les italiens ont renvoyé à
carte est de leur grand grand grand
metteur en scène fellini en tête
francesco rosi dino risi et comencini
l'amérique nous envoie john huston
martin ritt francis ford coppola et vous
dit allen
le hongrois miklos jancso le polonais
wajda les allemands schlöndorff et
herzog entreront en compétition et
remettront leur titre en jeu indien qui
se sont tous concertés pour choisir leur
sujet en effet l'amour est vraiment en
baisse on ne verra que des films sociaux
ou politiques
les dangers de la pollution atomique le
terrorisme le nazisme l'émancipation
féminine le syndicalisme la résistance
et puis toutes sortes de guerre y
compris celle du vietnam
et ce soir dans le film de miklos jancso
un phénomène qui il y a dix ans
paraissait une amusette et qui
maintenant a énormément influencé notre
monde
le phénomène hippie ce film ses airs
tirés de l'opérette de la comédie
musicale de rani et raddho qui va
chanter et danser sur l'écran du palais
mais l'ebit sont aussi un phénomène
socio politique pour moi l'esprit le
plus important c'est le désir de jeunes
gens de de protéger la liberté d'être
soi même que c'est ce que vous voulez
faire chaque époque apporte cette
mouvement d'al les années hippies j'ai
concentré dans l'histoire que
que les relations les sentiments sont
les sentiments qui qui ne sont eux qui
n'ont pas sont pas morts avec les années
60 ce qui fera pas dans le film c'est
que vous avez à la fois montrer ce que
le mouvement hippie ce que le les flower
pipe de 68 avait de nouveau de
révolutionnaire et en même temps ce qui
dans le mouvement hippie dure encore
aujourd'hui
bon écoute et je crois que dans le
mouvement des pires a apporté des choses
vraiment bon alors bon parce que sinon
les pokémon est écouté vous êtes habillé
presque comme un indien américain autres
collaborateurs les cheveux longs le blue
jeans et tout ça va casser des barrières
casser des barrières qui était vraiment
vraiment trop conservative pour que le
jeune aujourd'hui pour tout le monde
dans votre film on est un peu hanté par
l'idée du départ au vietnam de la guerre
c'est toujours le sujet qui est
difficile à digérer
par exemple meilleures firmes sur la
première guerre mondiale te ferme le
sens 37-38 la transition de renoir temps
après oui ça fait pas 20 ans que la
guerre du vietnam est finie oui mais
tout va plus vite
oui
[ __ ]
j'ai dit oui
key
à
mama
de bande à part
r de milos forman l'acte